Colin Kaepernick calls his white
adoptive parents racist because they
told him as a teen that cornrows is
unprofessional and that he looked like a
little Thug that's why I asked you about
the Commandments because honor them thy
mother and their father yeah and he's
like no so this is Dishonored this is
this is dishonestly he's calling his
parents racist yo dude they gave you
every opportunity they loved you talk
about spitting in their faces it's
disgusting it's completely disgusting
they adopted him but they were racist
total scumbag move total loser behavior
um this is just this is something
you're you're it's it's it's clout
chasing which is all he's really done
since he lost any position in the NFL
it's just Cloud Chase and he's just
punching up and it's it's interesting
because I guess his grift with you know
going after you know demonizing police
officers and going after the national
anthem has has gone on and I just hope
people look at this for what it is right
you know this guy has lost Target so
he's targeting the people that are
actually closest to him in his life and
he probably they probably were telling
him like you know hon it looks nice but
a lot of people are going to think
that's unprofessional and they weren't
wrong probably either at the time Tim
you mentioned evil earlier yeah I mean I
think this guy's evil but I think he's
the more banality of evil I mean I think
I just think it's an evil act I think
it's an evil I have to speak out against
your parents in in public but by the way
not not if not if you know unless you're
you know if your parents had done
something wrong right exact course yeah
obviously but in a situation like this
that were that were you know that I'm
talking about where you have people who
adopted you
raised you got to the point where
obviously very successful and and then
to turn around and slam them and then
use this word this epithet racist which
in our society today to label someone
racist is seen as the it's it's it's
worse than rape it's worse than murderer
it's this is the ultimate Evil it was
but I kind of think like they've beaten
a dead horse you know so now we're kind
of just like yeah yeah whatever you know
yeah
said something really stupid that's just
sort of that was my thought when I saw
this I was like yeah of course he did
the issue more so is that he's spitting
on his parents yeah that's kind of a
crazy thing like that you know in public
people do that a lot of parents too like
I mean not for nothing you know like you
they chose you they picked you and
you're gonna crap on them come on yeah I
mean it's also though that's what Harry
did that's like the thing that today
Prince Harry and Meghan Markle they had
like renounced their royalty but they're
like our children get to be Prince and
princesses
yeah well they demanded it they demanded
it that the children get the titles
they're the worst people they are they
they might just be evil you know Harry
might not actually actually be a windsor
right uh all I know is that whole story
I want a browser extension I want a
browser extension that when I turn it on
it erases their names from any website
so you never have to see their stupid
simply faces
well he's the same right so I do think
that Harry Megan is very indicative for
not just the young men out there but
also young women that this is this could
be you this could be you if you take
someone like that someone with every red
flag Under the Sun like Meghan Markle
and put her on a pedestal and put her in
charge of your entire life and all of
your Affairs give her that much of your
mental space that she will consume you
she will actually suck your soul which
we've seen or this this guy was he was a
war hero right he used to he used to go
and like party friends with his brother
you know brothers because of her you
know he's so he had to sell his guns he
did wow that's insane England wow yeah
because you can still have long guns in
England but I mean it's right and then
to to take someone and have them totally
control your life I mean that divorce is
going to be awful it's going to be right
it's going to be really bad yes
the tabloids are going to be so excited
well the templates are going to yeah and
and it's just I just think it's I think
it's sad but at the same time how many
of you have a friend in your life that's
been a Harry how many of you have been a
Harry in your life at some point and
said you know what I know they're this
way but I can fix them well I've known I
can fix them I've known some Megan's and
we've all known to Megan's we may have I
heard that she was talking about suing
South Park after they made fun of her on
that episode yeah then they came
everyone was like you are ridiculous and
then they were like no no we're not
really gonna sue them I no we're not she
cried apparently yeah I mean so stupid
she's just like the worst and I think
it's true like if you're dating someone
and they say something like your family
sucks like dump that person get rid of
that person because you know first your
family then your friends then yourself
they're gonna deprive you of everything
when you when you first meet someone
check their relationship with their
family right that's right so she she cut
herself off of her own family so her
she's got half siblings she's got a
father who by all accounts and purposes
actually does love her or at least had a
good you know tried to give her as much
she could uh she throws him under the
bus left and right then these half
siblings that she's completely cut them
off I would add Barack Obama to that
list by the way
um Who's got what how many have siblings
that you know they keep like popping up
every time we turn around by the way
shout out to Maliko Obama the right
Obama we elected the wrong the right
Obama that we like we elected the wrong
Obama the real Kenyan one right yeah
um uh and then
with with that if you've got someone
who's trying to get you to isolate
yourself from your family or your
friends just run yeah I was watching
some TV show I can't remember what it
was was it Fringe maybe I don't know she
was on it and I was just like well this
ruined the show for me maybe if I
watched it before she did all this
stupid Shenanigans I'd but I'm just sick
of the stories like uh I'm sick of her
tears oh it's just so awful it's really
just is she like is she is she like what
is she like the most hated celebrity
probably is she because she's like
because I don't know who else is a hated
celebrity hi Kardashian Kim Kardashian
no but Kim Kardashian I'm saying more
favorability I think I think probably
Mega Miracle yeah yeah she probably has
way more unfavorability in terms of the
fame she generates it's just so awful by
the way
um shout out to the Alx who just texted
me the live tweets of the ubl raid what
is it it's it's it's so high about there
right here
May 1st 2011 a huge window shaking bang
here in a bada bad I hope it's not the
start of something else
and uh
uh that's it foreign
tweeted it then a few hours later in the
morning Bin Laden is dead I didn't kill
him please let me sleep now
same to how many followers do you have
Now 44 000 followers
and oh he's like a CEO he's in software
good for him yeah
so I guess uh just going back to the
Colin Kaepernick thing
targeting the reason why I asked about
the uh what is it Taylor Silverman
replied to my Alex Stein story and said
AOC needs a nice Jewish boy like Alex oh
yeah
oh yeah that's right that's right it was
so upset here's the point I wanted to
bring up with the Kaepernick thing is
that it is the antithesis of the the
moral tradition of this country which a
component is honor thy father and thy
mother they want to sever you from your
roots they want you to attack your
parents and one of the things we see a
lot of his kids going up to college
coming back and then calling their
parents racist they're they're trying to
remove you from your family and destroy
the family so one of the reasons why I
don't think that the end goal is I can't
think of any other movements that have
ever done that in the past no right but
that's why I'm saying I never happened
in Cambodia or China That's why when
they say our goal is this and they point
to like post-modernism I'm like no no
their goal is going to be gulags their
goal is going to be the complete
destruction of society so they can build
something different and we don't know
what that will look like and it won't be
fun that happened on The Simpsons too
the separate do you remember the one
where uh Lisa is way older and she talks
about how her dad never did anything for
her and it's like he literally took you
to the music store when you could barely
speak oh yeah and this was they kind of
like retcon Yeah The Simpsons yeah oh
yeah and it's it's I know you're talking
about what is it a new episode or
something so it was a new episode where
she was talking about oh my father never
never did anything for me he hated me he
was always against my uh my musical
um you know my musical leanings
Etc and it's just not true because you
can go back to those old Simpsons
episodes and the the Crux of it was
always that you know of course Homer is
is a little bit mentally deficient and
obviously a drunk but he loves his
family and he always is trying to do the
right thing and it's it's his his
buffoonery that becomes the joke whereas
they've completely lost that because our
culture is so Hollow today when was this
episode from like last year yeah it was
last oh wow and of course age is an
agent do you see the one where they made
Abe Simpson gay
no the road Grandpa yeah they did it
they did an episode where what yeah yeah
where Abe Simpson ran had a friend who
turned out to be gay and then when he
found out his friend was gay ran away
and then never talked to him and felt
really bad about it and then went and
kissed him and they made out or
something oh weird they like kiss on the
lips and he was like well that wasn't so
bad or something like that there was
there there was the one where Homer had
a friend who was gay and the oh yeah and
the friend was like Homer I have to tell
you something I'm ho yeah Moe yeah
sexual what wait that that's what the
best line is like Homer I know how to
put this to you right right I prefer the
company of men who does who does it
that was an old an old episode though
was it yeah right
The Toy Story there's an episode where
bark gets mad because they're doing a
reboot of Itchy and Scratchy with a
female Itchy and Scratchy
because it's because the left that has
gotten in in Hollywood all they focus on
is deconstruction so it's deconstruction
of self it's deconstruction of story
it's deconstruction of character they do
not how to know how to tell stories
they don't understand any basic elements
of Storytelling and that's how you get
like what was it Superman had a gay son
that's why they deconstruct and redo old
stories
look at Star Wars look at Marvel it's
all skin suits they just go in and then
and the latest one though by the way and
I mentioned it before but it's yellow
stoning so yellow stoning is when
they'll take an actor
like in Yellowstone it's Kevin Costner
in 1923 it's Harrison Ford in Tulsa King
it's it's Sylvester Stallone and they'll
put them in a film or a TV show I guess
uh Taylor Sheridan and then they'll
introduce like woke elements in the
background so they use you know the
actor and the Aesthetics to pull you in
and then all of a sudden Monica comes on
screen and she's telling you about the
the horrific abuses and genocide of the
Native Americans and then here comes a
scene in Tulsa King where they talk
about and it's not even set in the past
right Tulsa King and they'll there's
like a redlining situation that goes on
where a black guy can't buy a car who's
got cash to pay for the car by the way
and suddenly it's just like totally
unlikely super anachronistic kind of
scene is just shoved in there and
Sylvester Stallone the only way that it
would work if he can't buy the car is
because there's something wrong with his
uh you know social credit score thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL pod cast hang out with us live
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and become
a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time